hey this is sort of weird former
Arkansas governor Mike Huckabee and
former US senator Rick Santorum are
hanging out in Russia and you can join
them for five to twelve thousand dollars
this is just the strangest and also sort
of most classless thing the two
Republicans were just in st. Petersburg
and they've been promoting a cruise you
can go on a cruise with them this is
just so bizarre it's called the Baltic
experience with governor Mike Huckabee
and guest speaker senator Rick Santorum
the cruise will stop in st. Petersburg
Russia Helsinki Finland Copenhagen
Denmark Holland Estonia Stockholm Sweden
and more this is for profit tickets are
five to twelve thousand dollars
depending on I guess how much time you
want to have with Mike Huckabee or Rick
Santorum and probably what size room you
get and what kind of a view you get from
that room on the big cruise ship how
could be promoted this on his Facebook
page as a quote unforgettable trip to
the Baltics he talks about the weather
very strange
Huckabee also I guess tweeting jokes
where he said enjoyed dinner on the
Baltic Sea with Jane Huckabee and dear
friends Rick and Karen Santorum note to
the media we are not here to collude but
to see if we can get the uranium back
that Hillary sold we told of lad we
could be more flexible after the
election and then Huckabee's own wife
who's just a hilarious woman responding
to the tweet we were colluding people
are actually talking about Russian
collusion and Russian connections here I
genuinely don't see it that way I see
this solely as a cringy money grab
unless you can get me some evidence that
this is anything more than that you
don't have to speculate what this is all
about it's just money yes ok Santorum is
connected to that Russian agent Maria
boo Tina and yes it seems like Betsy
DeVos was in Russia at the exact same
time as Huckabee in Santorum but I think
those are just coincidences I have no
reason to think that this is anything
but a brazen money grab from these two
what I really want to know is who's
willing to pay 12 grand to go on a boat
with Mike Huckabee and Rick Santorum I'm
not being sarcastic if you know anyone
who went on this thing
or is going on this thing up please get
him in touch with me what has gone
horribly wrong in your life that you
feel compelled to pay money to go on a
boat to talk to Mike Huckabee and Rick
Santorum and hear them speak that's who
I want to talk to and the only real
question mark about this for Santorum
and Huckabee this is just a
money-grabbing
strangely enough these things are much
more widely available than some people
might imagine and some of them are even
more cringy than this one